alright so i'd like to welcome and
welcome everybody today to this panel
called bountiful harvests about open
access collections as part of our open
access week 2012 events just as a
reminder to everybody this event is
being videotaped and the performance
will be posted performance pinterest ups
channel will be posted on the columbia
youtube channel actually on the cedars
youtube channel so you know please be
conscious of that and let us know you
don't want to appear on the web go let's
see what we can do to edit you out but
easier just to be aware and you know say
what you're comfortable saying to the
world so we have a great panel today i
know all three of our panelists well
from from the
were helped forward that it would rather
advanced open access here at Columbia
and honored and Burke at the theological
seminary so I look forward to hearing
what they what they have to tell us
about open access and collection about
we'll start with vanity Baker yes for ya
I'm think I know most people but I'm
Matthew Baker collection services
librarian at the burke library which is
just across the road there at broadway
and 120th i think we were all sort of
thinking that we would give a brief
introduction to the contexts in which we
work as relates to issues of open access
and so to that end a little bit about
the burke some of you may or may not
know it or had the chance to come on
over since 2004 it's been one of
Columbia's libraries and but prior to
that had a long history of its own as
the library of Union Theological
Seminary since it's well it's finding in
this part of town in 1908 at the same
time the Morningside campus of Columbia
was built and we serve a range of
patrons and scholars from Columbia
religion and sociology and other
generally Columbia students across the
disciplines Union students of course are
a very important group of users that we
have many students at uni live on campus
spend a lot of time in the library as
well as serving the students and faculty
of New York theological seminary and
range of national international
researchers who come to use the library
the mission of Union seminary which is
an important part of this discussion I
think it's a long history of socially
engaged ecumenical activists progressive
theology and you know in many ways that
mission dovetails with a lot of the
embassies of the open access movement
broadly speaking there's about it so
it's a relatively small institution I
think compared to the Columbia there's a
28 full-time faculty you up another 40
item and lecturers student FTE is in the
neighborhood of 250 275 and on the very
latest numbers another aspect of I think
that relates to the open access issues
we'll discuss here is the fact that the
Burke library is located on the campus
which sees a lot of coming and going of
students and faculty and staff and so
we're very privileged to have fairly
regular and very positive relationships
with a whole range of people in the
community and that that's actually
important part of i think the open
access points i'll mention a minute
mainly what what I although actually
Robin over is talking um the Union
seminary quarterly review has just gone
open access lecture you probably all
received a notice of that last summer
and Cedars is supporting that much of
what I do in fact all of what I do
really at this point is what we've green
open access that is leading to the
institutional repository academic
commons and outreach trying to make
faculty and students aware of academic
commons what it is to try and encourage
them to deposit their scholarship in the
academic commons answer any questions or
any questions or don't have any any
objections just questions in fact one of
the things that i always say is when
people ask about how it's going is when
i've talked to faculty at union and
tried to explain to them what the
academic commons is that there are there
questions at the end are along lines of
why would someone not do this that
that's the kind of context it is they
they're really sympathetic to it it's
been a positive response that people
have been very interested i think
and so far you know we again we're still
working I mean I I think in the context
of day to day I mean what I found is you
know in trying to make people aware of
open access and to get them to deposit
their work it's been much more effective
on a person-to-person basis you sent out
email reminders to them to the faculty
and staff but if I'd have to go back and
do things to be completely comprehensive
but I think almost all of the faculty
responses we've gotten had been in as a
result of just a conversation either
passing by an office or running into
somebody that Nina take oh did you see
the email oh you know can we sit down
and talk about this so because we have
as the smaller scale that I mentioned
you know that's been really conducive to
those kind of conversations I realize
that's something that's perhaps unique
to that to our context and so yeah so
we've we've had a pretty some some
pretty good numbers to positive so far
we've got quite a few others still in
the pipelines and some others who have
expressed interest so I'm hopeful that
you know hopefully by say the spring
will really have a pretty significant
increase in the
a work-related union related content and
academic commons I guess I'll leave it
at that thanks so my name is Megan
wotcha and i am the research and
instruction librarian for media and
Performing Arts at the Barnard College
Library and Barnard College for anyone
that's unfamiliar with it is under the
umbrella of Columbia University and it's
a small liberal arts college for women I
guess in terms of talking about the
communities that we're serving it's
about 2,400 undergraduate students that
are meant by 200 full-time faculty our
student to faculty ratio is along the
lines of once we consider all ft 10 to 1
so it's very much a service-oriented
institution it's about individualized
service and that is reflected in the
operations of our library and we have a
personal librarian program and so in
that position I serve as the personal
librarian i liaised to the dance and
theater departments and the film and
music programs so we have very strong
relationships with students and faculty
in our respective departments and
programs um what this means in terms of
our collection development policy that
was that you know Bernard the burner
college library is also a small
undergraduate library within a larger
University Library System so we collect
in order to support the undergraduate
curriculum of the college and we serve
as the primary collectors in women's
studies and in dance within the columbia
university system and so i will say that
i'm particularly interested in thinking
about open access as it relates to dance
materials not only because i select in
this area but also because of the very
unique challenges it presents both in
terms of the content types and in terms
of the community
so when I meet with students about their
research in the Performing Arts I tell
them it's really important to remember
two things first yes they're ephemeral
and second their collaborative and I
would say that this also applies to my
responsibilities in collection
development in dance the library
collects yes books but because of the
small size of the discipline they often
receive only one printing through a
small press we also collect journals
reviews sound recordings and images both
moving and otherwise all of which try to
document in some form the ephemeral body
that moves in space and time but I must
also remember that the field and on a
smaller level the department I serve our
collaborative it's composed of more
traditional historians but also critics
and practitioners all of which take in
and put out a diversity of different
types of content on these practitioners
I will say often don't have access to
tenured positions within the institution
but their intellectual output although
not a text is clearly evidence of the
research and teaching activities of the
college so when I kind of expand this
idea of collection development to
include issues of open access I'm faced
with many of the same reflecting
challenges that exist in a more
traditional print environment feel so
small that it lacked the most basic
staple of any discipline the
multi-volume encyclopedia until the
international encyclopedia of dance was
published in 1997 and so trying to
consider and undertaking such as a
subject specific repository would be
somewhat daunting and but possible a
field in which its publications again
are often printed by smaller presses
making them cheaper to purchase but they
are Philip availability and often their
preservation dependent on the passion of
the individuals that run them and we're
seeing this a lot through a lot of web
content that's currently available and
also film
you know whether we're going on VHS
where it still exists DVD or now moving
into streaming media that are held
hostage essentially by permission
holders dancers choreographers composers
musicians filmmakers all of which may
create a barrier to their distribution
so for me whether we're talking about
collecting open access resources or
making our resources our content
available via open access what I really
see though is not the challenge but the
incredible opportunities that it
presents and there's an opportunity to
partner with the communities that we
serve and if I'm in to bring to bring in
this year's OA week theme to have helped
them set the default to open access as
they move forward so I ask questions
like how can we as librarians
collaborate with faculty or their
professional organizations to preserve
and makes accessible content such as
their short run publications as faculty
increasingly request access to streaming
media for teaching purposes can we
partner with practitioners to make sure
it's available through something more
durable than YouTube and New York
University's hemispheric Institute has
actually made some really great
developments in this area I also ask how
can we make alternate forms of
intellectual outputs such as a
performance or increasingly perhaps a
digital humanities initiative more
visible within and outside of the
Columbia University and so I guess I'll
just say it's this this idea of
alternate forms of output that brings me
to my last collaborator and that is of
the undergraduate student I firmly
believe in the value of collecting
undergraduate feces into in
institutional repositories such as
academic commons
and yes this content documents the
research and teaching activities of the
University but in asking students to
submit their theses again there's an
opportunity there's an opportunity to
discuss discuss issues of intellectual
property there's an opportunity to talk
to them about considering how
information comes to them or perhaps how
information won't come to them upon
graduation but also to engage them with
the idea of not just being consumers but
producers of knowledge to think about
their work is participating within a
larger scholarly conversation
undergraduates are asking some of the
most interesting research questions and
regardless of their discipline whether
it's in the Performing Arts or in
neuroscience and behavior and their work
has the opportunity i believe to make an
impact and in the case of academic
commons it it already has incorrect me
if i miss state this but the per item
download for undergraduate theses is
second only to ebooks within academic
comments so that's ahead of
dissertations and so really the way that
I think about it is the research process
of both our faculty and our students is
not complete until it is published and
given a very public audience and I
believe that we have a really great role
to play in that process
great thanks well as as many of you know
I'm Pamela Graham and I work here as
director of our global studies division
and I also direct our Center for Human
Rights documentation and research I
wanted to thank Rob and Catherine and
Cedars for putting this group together
and inviting me to be part of it and I
kind of half jokingly wondered if you
had to get special permission from spark
to have a an open access panel that
doesn't have a scientist because I
always associate so much of this
discussion with the sciences and it's
obviously been really important in
central to all the issues related to
publishing but we're gaggle of humanists
here and we all work in very different
kinds of disciplines both social
sciences and humanities in our case so
we hope that this can surface some of
the things that may be different or
unique to those disciplines and
hopefully there are those of you out
here who can join in a discussion when
I'm finished and that could be one theme
we could be keeping in mind so I wanted
to just say a bit about our collection
development work in our unit and how
open access is factoring into that in
our overall observations on the
scholarly communication and the
scholarly communities that were engaged
with in doing this work and I'll give a
little bit of context for anyone who may
not be familiar with our work and the
nature of the collecting that we do
within our our global studies division
are our unit was until recently known as
area studies for many decades and we're
still area studies with a little a and a
little s now although we have the the
more popular name now of global studies
but we are a unit of seven people
including myself who have subjects
specializations and focus on collecting
material from throughout the world and
our coverage and includes middle east
and islamic studies peters our librarian
for that area he's here with us today we
also cover south asia jewish studies
Latin American and Iberian studies
Russian your
eration in Eastern European studies
African Studies and we work very closely
with Cornell University to do more
in-depth coverage of South East Asian
Studies which is their specialty they
have a preeminent collection of Beck
Cornell I can add to the picture that we
also of course have an east asian
library which is a separate unit that
does all of the collecting from from
those regions of the world and then
within our disciplinary divisions of art
and architecture history and humanities
Social Sciences we have many other
people joining in this overall effort of
collecting from throughout the world so
just a few things to give you some sense
of what we do in the scale and scope of
what we're doing or collecting is really
quite extensive so as you've already
heard its extensive geographically and
that we're pretty much covering the
entire world and the work that we do but
it's also very deep in that we will
collect in many languages languages you
have probably never heard of but that
matter to someone and that is important
to the research process especially at an
institution like Columbia that is so
global and has both departments programs
Institute centers professional degree
programs that are all very heavily
engaged in the world and need to either
train people to think about the world or
train scholars to be specialists with
very deep roots in understanding the
world in terms of our collecting I
estimate and these are kind of rough
estimates just for our unit that we
probably work with a network of at least
40 to 50 in-country vendors many of them
very small businesses or family
businesses to procure the information
that we get the materials that we get we
spend about 1.3 million dollars a year
on the print collecting that we bring in
that's rough estimate and that's
probably an intake of over 30,000 items
a year that we bring into this library
system the electronic expenditures which
are really hard to estimate but last
year it seemed to be around 183 thousand
dollars
that is less than fifteen percent of
what we spend in print so as you can see
we're still dealing in a scholarly
communication process that is mostly
print throughout the world and where you
haven't seen a transfer or replacement
of digital of print with digital we
still to capture the record have to
engage pretty deeply in that and that
doesn't mean we don't have a lot of
digital content to monitor but that just
gives you a sense of the balance of
what's happening so what does that
digital landscape look like and had it's
open access factored into that picture
you know there's a fair amount of
historical we call historical content
publishers like Adam Matthew Gale and
usually scanning my bike performed
collections and reselling them is
basically what happens but there's a
fair amount of historical kind of
archival document collections in the
digital publishing there's collaborative
efforts like the center for research
libraries or consortia of libraries that
partner with commercial publishers to
help produce products like the world
newspaper archive generally what's
happening there is content that's not
really commercially viable to go out and
be distributed is is made possible to be
published because of some kind of non
profit profit collaboration that helps
push some of this into the digital realm
and then of course there's all kinds of
digital projects out there that national
libraries or academic libraries or
cultural organizations digitize and get
content out that's freely available so
that's a part of this landscape as well
and it's very fragmented and very hard
to get a sense of what that is overall
but that's a piece of the picture in
terms of more current sources there's
clearly a lot of licensing of news and
other current data and information that
we pay for a lot of big vendors like
fective and lex LexisNexis have this and
then we have ebook products that I often
call the boutique ebook products because
they can be very often not complying
with some of the standards we'd want to
see for that some may be free some main
not be free and again it can be very
fragmented and challenging to find ways
to make them available they're usually
set up and marketed to local users not
to an academic library environment so we
have a lot of challenges and seeing a
lot of content come in that way and so
that's where open access is so important
to us because that's really in my eyes
the growth area of the digital for a lot
of what we're covering in our group and
by open access I think I have a very
broad and liberal definition of that I
know there's probably a lot of energy
that goes into defining what open access
means and yes in some cases it is the
situation that I guess is common here
where you see open access is this
alternative to the conventional
conventional publishing models that
charge fees both for access and may
limit rights to use of material we
certainly see open access coming up as
an alternative and in some ways to
displace or replace those kinds of
models but we also see in our world
sometimes the alternative is not those
prevailing kind of commercial models but
the alternative is nothing that you just
don't see publishing if you don't see
open access publishing because or you
see the print publishing that continues
but that then we'll have a very low
impact because of the challenges of
seeing print get disseminated and
discovered and all of that so in many
cases open access as having this
additive effect not a replacing effect
adding more access and more content that
that researchers can have it also is a
very important you know there's a lot of
discussion about what that does to the
dynamic of knowledge transfer and
information transfer and we see
knowledge being produced especially in
the developing world very
underrepresented and that with it often
is called the south-north flow not
happening nor does the south-south flow
happen
but the more that we can be aware of
this content and do things to facilitate
discovery and access the more that that
kind of exchange can happen and the
better we think for the scholarly
communication process so so are you know
our sense of open access may include
aggregator sites that pull together open
access journals and it may include just
open web content which may stray a bit
from the conventional sense of open
access but that we are very aware and
cognizant of the role we may have with
that kind of content so I'll just you
know give a few quick examples of things
that have caught our eye on ways that we
work with open access and then we can
maybe open things up and hear hear from
some of you um and I can draw examples
from the Latin American area because I
was the Latin American Studies librarian
for many years here and that's the part
of the world that I I know the best and
that I'm closest to there have been some
really successful aggregators of open
access journals based in Latin America
and some of them ranked among the top
portals in the world for open access
journals and that's a significant
achievement and as a Latin American asst
it makes me kind of proud that these
projects really took off one is the
scientific online library known as CLO
that started in Brazil and now has many
different national sites and by
scientific it's good to know that often
and translating from the Spanish science
Synthetica is really meant to be
scholarly not science and the pure sense
of science although that's a new ones
that doesn't always come through but
that cielo health about almost a
thousand journals at this point in spans
both sciences humanities Social Sciences
and they offer a systematic way of
producing having searchability
download free download that everything's
licensed under the Creative Commons
licensing its peer reviewed journals
there's a fairly strict process of
reviewing journals before they're
admitted into the Cielo network and they
are very conscious of having metrics to
track use and impact and they're very
active in the open access movement and
you know they have a motto of loss
science doesn't exist to reflect that if
you are publishing in a way where
something's not exposed or disseminated
it's like you're not publishing and so
they have a real consciousness of that
and have been very active at promoting
that this is produced with government
support in Brazil which I guess makes it
possible but it's done a lot I think to
change the culture of publishing in in
Brazil and and other Latin American
countries and we have linked I follow
CLO from its inception in the early 90s
and we've linked to it we've done
whatever we could within the library to
make sure our users knew about the
particular journals we have and we're
getting to the point where we actually
are dropping print subscriptions I mean
this is something people did 20 years
ago make me in other fields but we
actually feel secure enough to have a
good solid open access platform like
this that we feel okay that we don't
have to have print just to be sure that
a particular journal is is available and
maybe we can coordinate of all
northeastern Latin American collections
one collection can keep a print kind of
archive and we can really turn to this
aggregator is a good point of access and
discovery there's another similar
product bed a leak which is based in
Mexico also has over 800 journals so
same kind of principles and covering
some other countries other subjects but
those two repositories I guess you might
call them reported say rank very highly
in the world in terms
of good models for how to do this and
again you know just as a point of
comparison the only index we had for
Latin American Studies journals was
really the Hispanic American periodicals
index and that has covered in its
lifetime since the early 70s about 500
journals it's indexed between CLO and
read the league even if there's some
overlap you could say well maybe there's
at least 1,200 journals being covered in
there that are all full-text searchable
whereas happy was just an index with no
full text and so alone the discovery
process alone is transformed by seeing
more of these open access products and
that's really been a real real positive
effect I think on our communities then
just quickly for open web content our
our division ages ago got in the game of
creating subject directories to web
resources years ago and that was what
was happening and some of those are
still going and we think about the role
of doing this and not everything is
exposed well to the web so we still
think there's a role for curating the
open web in some degree and so we do
that in a few different ways we still
have some of these portals and they're
probably undergoing some revision and
transformation but that's been an
existing way that we try to highlight
open access content we have actually
Peter L mentioned that you run a blog a
mere access to middle middle east and
islamic resources that is a blog that
tracks open access resources about and
from that area of the world and you're
welcome to when we talk if there's
anything you want to share about that
experience but that's been another way
to try to make more visible resources
that might not easily just sort of pop
up in searching or in other ways and
then finally we've begun a web
collecting program here at columbia
where we are archiving websites and
we're doing in a few different subject
areas or most extensive effort is
happening in human rights with a human
rights web archive in a beta prototype
but that archive just went up recently
and we selected websites related to
human rights human rights organizations
about 500 organizations we're regularly
capturing their websites and those
websites contain a lot of different
kinds of content but they we certainly
look for sites that are going to have
publications working papers journals
other kinds of material of scholarly
value and that's getting saved in the
course of doing that web archiving we
also do indexing so that you have a much
better environment to search this
content than the free web and we have
some enhancement that would make it
easier to navigate this corpus of
material we're gathering around the
subject and I see this kind of web
collecting in some format is really
vital for the area studies librarians to
be capturing this this vast amount of
open access open web content that's
coming out and our challenges are how to
do that in a way that makes it easy for
people to know and discover what can we
do that's different than what the open
web can do obviously there's a
preservation piece because we are trying
to preserve and keep some of this
content so that's been i think our other
major role in working with building
collections from the open access
material in the world now i haven't
mentioned academic commons sorry i have
a gun tab but i have to say that we i
think are more at a starting point of
working with our communities to help
build academic commons we have a lot of
different disciplines a lot of
humanities disciplines and we I think
have a lot of good potential to draw
from those communities to continue to
feed academic commons we have global
centers now columbia a global centers
based around the world and that's
another important production site so to
speak that could feed academic commons
and we've already had discussions about
how we can we can go about doing that
but i think in some of the discussions
we've had we've kind of reaffirmed or
agreed that the different research
communities may require different
proaches in terms of how we describe and
how we you know how we can engage
interest in academic commons that there
are different priorities and interests
in different research areas and being
attuned to that I think it's really
important to gaining and understanding
and then a willingness to participate
and so we know that would have to be
part of the work we do is we work to
help support act until my comments so so
I'll just leave it at that then you'll
see we have some questions all right
well before we open the floor question
to thank all the speakers for sharing
with us their insights into open access
collection development and take
advantage of my position as moderator to
sort of have a couple of you know
off-the-cuff responses and I think one
of the things that really struck me was
that often when you hear talk about open
access these days it's within the
context of the skyrocketing cost of
subscriptions to terminals and I have to
say I'm actually really impressed that
that didn't come up once at all today I
think part of that reflects that this is
a panel of humanists and so often
Sciences where were those journals
really cost so much writing another ass
it's really important to know is that
we're actually not just talking about
journals as though they're the
be-all-end-all most college education
and scala output the fact is scholarly
communication is changing and there are
so many different ways in which people
are communicating their research and so
many different types of resources that
people are using to fuel their own
research that live on the web in
different formats and aren't just
journal articles anymore and so I think
that is a really important need a point
to highlight and underline
I think something else whenever I try
and describe into the work study
students were hiring what it is we do
with with academic commons and what open
access collection building is really
about you know I struggled with it for a
while but I finally settled on what I
think is it a good metaphor it's an
inside-out library because what we
normally do with the library collection
development is we go out in the world we
buy stuff from other people and bring it
back for local use within the Columbia
community and we have limitations that
mean that it's really for that local use
and what we're doing when we're building
open access collections like the human
rights web archive and like academic
clump comments is we're gathering stuff
that we have access to locally and
packaging it making it available for use
throughout the world and that's really
you know one of the most powerful things
I think about open access you know when
I think about what we've been able to do
with that collection is to see the
downloads that happen you know to see
people coming from all over the world to
access these open access collections is
it really is it an amazing and
empowering thing and it really makes you
feel like you're having an impact so
yeah
something we all share on this panel of
a sense of contributing to a larger
community from within the colony
universe so with that I can just add a
brief go to what you said excuse me when
you talk about the cost of cereals it's
often not the cost of the subscription
but the cost of figuring out where you
can get a journal and all the
communication labor it takes to keep
making sure you get the issues you know
you some professor wants something from
a smaller city in Bolivia the work it
takes to figure out how to get that the
number of times you have to go back and
forth sometimes when it doesn't come
regularly our considerable cost so
that's part of how we sometimes think
about it even though indeed the actual
cover price can be extremely low in many
cases I just found that as well I mean I
think the I guess what you call the
cultural issues are on open access as
opposed to the legal or as opposed to
the technical those are the things that
I spent the most time I think just
discussing and as you say is you know
moving towards new models of scholarly
communication you know this sort of
small steps things like the monthly
statistics report from academic commons
a sense that scholars gain seeing how
many people have access to content is
really powerful and immediate in a way
that
you know is I think a really important
piece of moving this academic commons in
particularly but open access approaches
to scholarly communication more
generally forward and making the case in
ways small and increasingly large
any questions from the group I wonder if
it sounds like
but what is the model
struggling Lautenberg
well i mean i think the journal
production has been fairly healthy and
you know it I don't think there's as
much of a commercial presence it's still
scholarly societies academic
institutions that are producing and you
know there's just been this really
strong and quick growth in these portals
as soon as they were instituted and they
provided a good and clear model of how
you could publish online that attracted
a lot of a lot of support and a lot of
journals appeared in those portals I
still think there's still subsidization
that happens that doesn't happen here
that supports publishing and you know
again this is kind of different than
what you're seeing in other areas like
the e-book market is is almost
non-existent in Latin America but for
journals we've seen a much stronger
growth of that and in even when you know
you're paying for print journals again
they're they're rarely expensive they're
twenty-five dollars a year or fifty
dollars a year at the most so it's a
very different kind of landscape but
again the real challenge is keeping
track of what's coming out where it is
how to get it and and you do see a trend
of many journals that come out and don't
survive so you see quite a lot of of
that happening and the ones that
persists are in the end much much viewer
it was really struggling you should be
talking about
the collaboration aspect
I wonder if you could all drill down
the more
these you'll clearly don't think of
yourselves as they know it offers that
are whatever you know but did you have
to work together a dress a bit more how
you do that in here your daily work and
how how going for we would want to go
like a subway first um it's a really
great question I mean in addition to my
relationships with my colleagues of
barnard library and my colleagues at the
center for digital research and
scholarship I also see one of my
greatest collaborators is the faculty
member I think one of the challenges of
engaging undergraduate students it's
it's a question of how do we engage a
community with issues of open access
when they already have a very high level
of access to content at least during the
four years that they're here so you know
they have questions they don't yet have
questions about how information exactly
is coming to them and they're not really
thinking about their work is
participating in a scholarly
conversation yet but by partnering with
faculty and having the faculty kind of
support some of the principles that I
discuss with them that really does
engage them to go and submit their
theses to the comments and so that's
where the greatest success is I find
in terms of collaborating I think are
trying to make connections with faculty
Anna I have to be careful not to be too
much of a pest that's one thing I think
you know I it's sort of a fine line
sometimes but I don't think I've
offended anybody yet I hope not but the
other and more substantive part of that
is just get given some of the remarks
that I made earlier about the mission
and the vision of many of the folks who
come in to the burgh focus on social
justice just as an example I mean they
recently are having a just started a
very engaging series of lectures on
economy new economies in theology and
extra had Justice stiglitz there in
conversation with other Union faculty
and so that in so issues of for example
the ways in which open access approach
to scholarly communication part x I
think very very obviously of a gift
economy of oven the non-rival risk
nature of scholarly communications
particularly humanity so having the
conversation along those lines
tremendous amount of openness I mean and
also that I think some of the things
that Pamela mentioned although in
obviously slightly different directions
there's a real interest in connecting
globally both as as scholars and as
practitioners and in both directions
that were you know as you know reaching
out and pushing out scholarship in the
most Broadway but also drawing upon the
fullest range of theological writing and
experience is religious there and I
think it's very easy to in the course of
conversation and in trying to and I
think a lot of it is
you know you read about this I think
probably almost every sort of type of
outrage that you might encounter is that
everyone's very busy and everyone has a
lot on their plates and so how what is
it about in this case an institutional
repository or another case a journal or
a portal or a project what is it that
will actually encourage or allow a
particular scholar person to have to
have that aha moment you know okay this
is interesting tell me more I think it's
just different from person to person and
it just as I said it's a very there's a
lot of running into folks and and and a
great sort of focus on hospitality there
which makes some of these conversations
very easy to have but thinking about
what this person this person is studying
what
I can say with a faculty obviously we we
have very close relationships we
cultivate very strong relationships and
that also as Matthew was saying and
Megan as you were saying I think we can
really appeal to a rule either sympathy
or the way that they are tuned to the
barriers in the world for the flow of
information and that's a very powerful
motivation to promote open access and
many scholars go off into the world
faculty go off into the world they would
come back and lament that they didn't
have access to certain things when they
were away so I think that's an easy
point where we can see a lot of
understanding the other collaboration I
think that's been important is our work
with external collaborators we have many
different associations for librarians
specialist in different world regions so
all of our librarians are very active in
those different associations some of
them tied to the studies associations
for those parts of the world so we have
a presence and involvement in those
forums and those communities are really
important for helping us keep aware of
what's going on and share information
about what we know and even in some
cases there are projects that can be
based out of those kinds of forums so
that's been a very important network
that supports our general collecting
work and supports our attempts to get a
grasp on the open web and then with the
human rights web archive on you know
that archive consists of material that
we have captured from lots of different
organizations and we have always called
them contributors and always approached
this to see them as stakeholders in this
in this corpus of material it's built on
what they have produced we asked them
permission to grab their websites and we
if we don't hear from them we have a
process of going ahead to do it anyway
but with a clear notification and
understanding that we would stop
capturing at any point
and remove content if someone no longer
wants it to be there so we work with
those producers of information and one
of our goals as we continue to evolve
this archive is that we could work more
closely with those collaborators and
give them best practices for how to
structure their websites so it would be
easier for us to archive and download or
capture I should say and so that we
would want to put out something back
that share some expertise we may have
about good ways to both expose their
information and make it easier for
anyone who wants to save our archive
that material and then of course we're
helping they can turn to us as a source
of a backup or of a at least an archive
of what they've produced so that
collaboration with the creators and
information is an interesting new new
dynamic that I don't think we have going
on in the pre open web kind of error so
comparative in maintenance presentation
things are peppered throughout breathe
and open access is represent something
of a growth area and all of us identify
opportunities for talking about open
access or what what you sir that made it
to the institutional repository and I
just wonder if any of you could comment
on how whether or how he collaborates me
to change to accommodate this
process I mean
it's it's to some extent I know it as
librarians we have many things on our
plate so to some extent including a
heavy element of outreach or or
development in these areas is tithing to
that but at the same time you know
support of seeders and of other similar
groups within the library is really
crucial they're having that expertise
and yeah I think it's probably
librarians would be the first to talk
and we know that where we hope that this
is where things are going you know at
whatever pace they are going and so on
and I feel like it frees up you know
whether it's in terms of budgets or in
terms of just work load it free it
ultimately could and this is maybe a bit
more abstract but it ultimately could I
think free up libraries to think a lot
more imaginatively about you know their
role as curators of scholarly knowledge
of new projects of new directions for
scholarly communication and for
archiving the world's knowledge and so
on so there's you know as these genres
evolve and you know I feel like there's
there's a lot of instrumental roles that
library
it's can be played are of course our
plane but even more 72 reshaping pushing
forward and in a really exciting way
yeah and also say echo what you've said
and also rob as well in terms of
academic commons come being and said i
really like that um you know it's funny
because in damp sand library of
civilized libraries and librarians have
always paid a pretty interesting role
and the new york public library for the
performing arts for instance likes to
describe itself as part library but also
part museum that they actively preserve
the art form and the lost i mean if i
can back up i was going to say the last
20 years but let me back up a little bit
further I mean dance in higher education
is actually a pretty new thing itself
it's always kind of been here um
particularly on this campus there were
dance classes over at Barnard and at
Teachers College where Martha Graham was
teaching in the 30s um but it was in the
physical education department and it
wasn't until a boom that kind of came
with post-modernism in the mid 60s going
into the 70s that they started forming
dance departments and that it was
recognized as a discipline right and so
this is also when library collections
really start building themselves within
colleges and universities and so it's
one of the reasons we're facing these
problems but it also means that um that
librarians have very strong
relationships both with the community of
scholars and the command the community
of practitioners they don't always talk
to it than other the scholars and
practitioners but they do talk to the
librarians right and so through this
there are organizations like the dance
heritage coalition based in New York
which has done some really important
work in terms of collecting the art form
teaching basic standards for
preservation but also setting early
standards for film preservation they
were one of the first instituted to do
that
so in terms of open access and creating
new content this is just beginning to
become part of the conversation but
because those collaborative
relationships are already formed I
really do believe that you again you
know collecting new types of content in
new ways and that those are it's a
really great question and I think
overall I'm fairly optimistic but I also
have to be honest and say I have some
real concern about the sort of
transition phase as we move into feeling
more responsible for having stewardship
of open web content you know as you can
see from when I described all that print
coming in the door hitting us that that
this growth in open web content isn't
having a replacement effect it's largely
in my view additive to a lot of what we
still have to do and so it feels like to
actively curate that it's an additive
kind of function that lands on top of
all the many things that we already do
and we don't see a lot of opportunity to
to push some things off the plate so I
think it's a real juggling act at this
moment and it has to make us think
seriously about what what are the
appropriate roles within libraries and
whether we can just transition existing
models and just add in these additional
kinds of responsibilities or whether
there's new roles to be developed for
our human rights web archive we were
fortunate to have funding from the
mellon Foundation and that's been
helping us with getting things going and
we had a kind of new role come out of
that the web collection curator that
worked mostly on the technical aspects
of how to capture and set up that
process but got into some of the review
of content and what we need and it may
be that we need some new roles like that
that work in collaboration with people
with with very deep subject knowledge
and that there can be some share you
know responsibilities because I'm a
little skeptical of just adding on and
it sounds so go out now and collect the
web you know it sounds like crazy so I'm
not then how could I ever really
seriously tell someone that's what we
must do so you know we have to be very
thoughtful and very aware of how much
and we have to define boundaries
obviously of how much we feel we can do
and what what's most important for us to
do versus what we can trust someone else
may take care of I mean if I can jump in
here as well you know I said I conceive
of academic commons and open access in
general as being it inside a library I
think the flip side is there's a
perspective from which what we're doing
is what libraries have always done which
is curate and disseminate the man's
knowledge and so from that perspective
you know we need to be in this space but
the question is exactly how do we do
that how is that scalable when you're
talking about curating the open lab I
mean that's that's blooming you know who
can who can take that on and so you have
to figure out you know what are the
parts that can be done but I think
another aspect of it is to go back to
talking about collaboration you know
finding those those spaces for radical
collaboration with I you know across the
discipline of librarianship across the
profession but also with others in other
areas that have the skills and the
abilities to bring to the table to make
something like web creation possible I
mean you know the internet archive is
they part of this project web archiving
project because they have the technology
and the resources to help make it
possible and so those kinds of
collaborations are essential going
forward in a way where historically
maybe they weren't because again you
were just building a collection for
local use so you were worried about
what's in our stacks and not thinking
about you know what's I would upon a
server somewhere that you know we can
share responsibility for providing
enhanced access to for this Kali
community
I think that that's an important an
important opportunity to underline that
there are opportunities for increased
cooperation with others across the world
made possible by that networked
environment at the same time as it
presents challenges
right well any any last questions or
last thoughts it asked a science
question and see if we can answer in
that case thank you all for joining us
today for this event and I hope you all
join us tomorrow afternoon here in this
room again fine too much dr. Cruz Olivia
socotra advisory office represented by
copyright
wait don't explain